right tonight is game five between our
vegas golden knights and the colorado
avalanche
but before we get to the hockey game we
have a big
air hockey game take a look
welcome to the first ever las vegas now
eight news now air hockey challenge it's
myself jc fernandez taking on
ted florendo yes now the winner will get
the golden stick
and the loser must put on a colorado
avalanche jersey
for social media the rules are simple
first one to seven wins here we go
come on face off
let's go
[Music]
i don't know if it's gonna work who
injures themselves in air hockey
i don't know it's craziest thing right
so what do you do i
i don't know i i what do you think i
have to get us up
we gotta get stuck we gotta get us up we
gotta get a summit because i just can't
this is my pointing hand for weather hey
buddy listen i need you man victim i
really need you
i'm hurt i'm injured can you come in
last favor i promised last favor
okay yeah come on you're here now you're
here okay we're good
steps in to play air hockey this is not
legal i i hear you're a little rough
you took my man ted out of the game oh
yeah i can take it
he helps your standing flex and now
let's go you know the stanley cup before
right
have you ever held the golden stick
before not like that i haven't all right
let's go all right it's 2-1 let's go
oh yeah
oh whoa whoa whoa whoa sorry watch watch
the head
all right three one three one
gonna score himself
all about defense
one shot
[Applause]
might want to find a tailor get this
fitted
let's go all right okay all right come
on come on come on come on
[Applause]
well this goes to ted battled through
injury adversity
well done thank you shane thank you guys
jc great game
yeah guys
how's your arm over there ted oh it's
getting better thanks
hanging in there thanks for asking yeah
and you got the the jersey we have to
burn that light oh yeah that's what i'm
talking about
that's what i'm talking about here's the
here's the best part i know you lost
jc but you did win with the tightest
shirt
yeah i did well i don't know shane's
shirt was pretty tight as well i think
mine is either first or maybe second
i would say first i measured you guys i
was like okay yeah you won for sure
i was definitely last place well ted
you're the champion now so
congratulations you don't have to defend
your title
next year at this time right so watch
the arm again
with switching sides throughout the uh
throughout the process as well
yeah i didn't notice that i didn't
notice that yeah yeah so what's going on
there
we'd like to thank game nest arcade for
letting us use their arcade and their
air hockey table
and the nightline by drumbots the golden
knights will take on the colorado
avalanche in denver tonight for game
five
it's round two of the stanley cup finals
and is tied at two games of peace
go nights eight news now sports team
will have complete coverage tonight
including sports director
chris matthews who is on the ground in
denver the puck
drops at 6 p.m i know